here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show the Internet with the us
be better off Christian with a
parliamentary system in terms of
legislative effectiveness and
constituency representation whoa well I
don't think it's my job to pretend I'm
smarter than the founding fathers who
just said are so smart having said that
I think a parliamentary system well you
know we have to say that chief just not
Chief Justice Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg said if we were starting again
we would we would you I think we both
have experience of it and what's great
about it is when you elect a majority in
parliament that majority can act I once
spoke to Paul Martin who had been our
finance minister and Bob Rubin and Paul
said that he called Bob up they were
talking about some financial matter and
Bob said well what are you up to Paul
and he said oh well I just presented my
budget to Parliament today and Bob said
oh you know how long is it gonna get you
how long will it take you to get that
budget through the legislature and he
said we did it today you just vote on it
I present it and also talked about it we
vote on it and also there's no real lame
ducks right people don't hang around for
a long time in a parliamentary system
after they're ineffective except Israel
they just recycle again yeah well now
why do you know what do you say that
well almost everyone who's been Prime
Minister is still alive he is a member
of parliament and almost every member of
it will eventually be Prime Minister
they have a kind of a road but I mean
you know the government can fall with
they get rid of the guide still the
refrain yeah I mean there's no Nixon's
then that situation would never happen
in a parliamentary system the chris
Christie situation might go on in New
Jersey because chris Christie as I was
about to say looks like that did I ever
tell that David Wildstein guy is
throwing him under the bus Wow and if
you thought traffic was blocked before
sousou's very well thinking of how the
government works wouldn't it make more
sense for government oversight hearings
to be held by a neutral body say the
judicial branch rather than Congress
which is always partisan but two things
no these are great two things first of
all the Opposition in Britain the
minority actually does the the key the
oversight their committee is in fact
charged by the minority but second of
all we have the general Accountability
Office and the Inspector General's and
those are competitively neutrals ones in
the executive branch ones in the
legislative branch the vast majority of
what you see us doing an oversight comes
from the Inspector General's who
actually are in the executive branch the
presentation is adversarial but the fact
underlying facts normally collect the
IRS investigation I had asked the
inspector general to pick that up and
that's really where the report on
targeting conservative groups came from
it came from an executive branch
appointee but as always no they didn't
they didn't target just concerned oh yes
they did
no they yes no no you know you can
continue to have that but the facts as
of today show that the targeting not did
we send out a note but the targeting was
strictly these Tea Party groups that got
well that's biggest tea party that's
because the tea party groups have names
like [ __ ] the IRS so of course the IRS
is gonna look into it that a little more
just like when police get a letter that
says I want to kill police they look
into that a little more than the one
that says I want to kill hookers they
normally have I want to live for the
Constitution but but the fact the fact
is though that it sounds like it's you
know Henry Waxman and I went back and
forth very much trying to get to the
truth but when Henry was in the minority
and the majority in the house against
bush he was very effective and and one
of the reasons was quite frankly that he
was looking for Fault in an
administration every Oversight Committee
should look for fault in every
administration right that's the only way
you keep a country clean but at some
point don't you have to
let it go when I mean like I don't want
to say the bad word Benghazi but you
know at some point I mean it's just
plain that you know a bad thing happened
but you have to work backwards from
president and blackenstein as evil so to
really believe I still don't know I
still can't hear anybody on your site
succinctly tell me what the scandal is
there but but also in that case and I
think actually the same is true somewhat
ironically of the furor over Chris
Christie and 2016 prospects both sides
run the risk of over playing their hands
and focusing on a substance free
speculative conversation about 2016
prospects instead of focusing on the
nitty-gritty difficult questions raised
by both of those situations right there
are in a real question I mean I'm a fan
of MSNBC but they look like one of those
nature shows where the pack of hyenas
are taking down a warthog and I'm
starting to feel bad for the warthog you
know I mean I'm not gonna ask which
party is which in this metaphor I think
we're just gonna leave warthog is chris
christie
in that metaphor yes absolutely look I
think MSNBC is reporting on Chris
Christie if you actually look at it if
you look at what critic Steve Kornacki
did and others it is very fact driven
I'm not saying it's not fact driven
absolutely it is and I hate that false
equivalency MSNBC when the great things
about it and I am a fan is that they are
scrupulous fact checkers whereas Fox
News are scrupulous fact makers one
thing I like about that network is that
they tell me about important stuff and I
feel like this story has crowded out a
lot of other news that's more I think
it's a problem nationwide to the extent
that it has been a conversation about
what's gonna happen in 2016 we've got
problems right now and you don't I don't
I don't don't don't become them don't be
obsessive he has been the worst of that
like it worked in terms of ratings isn't
that what drives this course that's what
it drives a conversation worth having
and to an extent it needed to be covered
I think that was done fastidiously on
MSNBC Zaire I don't think they're the
road networks just gonna say you are I
agree with you about the problem which
is true across the board about over
speculation about an election that is a
ways off and we don't know how much
these situations are gonna impact see
got the job Benghazi senator Feinstein
releases a report only a few days ago
that cast blame on many parts of the
government some of which there's still a
question of if there's another threat
like that will the military will the
State Department be able to react so the
story of Benghazi is four people died
let's make sure it doesn't happen again
and quite frankly senator well if that's
what you had been saying all along we
wouldn't even be having a cover story
that's actually what that's actually as
you've heard not good before d say I
I've been talking about that I'll give
you every quote I've made regardless of
that the question is in all these these
embassies particularly in in Africa vast
area large the United States do we have
a plan in place to make sure there's
either sufficient security or these
facilities aren't there men and women
will die in support of our nation's
diplomacy the question is are the
systems in place to minimize that death
ambassador Chris Stevens was a career
professional he knew the risk that's all
true but at the same time in retrospect
we could have done a better job we need
to do a better job in the future let's
let's end on that note
- a better job in the future Real Time
with Bill Maher ask villainous guests
your questions right after the show at
hbo.com or on Twitter